Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
CAD stands for computer aided design, basically
a digital 3D model of a scene.
Here is an incredibly difficult problem: what
if we give the computer a photograph of a
living room, and the output would be a digital,
fully modeled 3D scene.
A CAD model.
This is a remarkably difficult problem: just
think about it!
The algorithm would have to have an understanding
of perspective, illumination, occlusions,
and geometry.
And with that in mind, have a look at these
incredible results.
Now, this clearly sounds impossible.
Not so long ago we talked about a neural network-based
technique that tried to achieve something
similar and it was remarkable, but the output
was a low resolution voxel array, which is
kind of like an approximate model built by
children from a few large lego pieces.
The link to this work is available in the
video description.
But clearly, we can do better, so how could
this be possible?
Well, the most important observation is that
if we take a photograph of a room, there is
a high chance that the furniture within are
not custom built, but mostly commercially
available pieces.
So who said that we have to build these models
from scratch?
Let's look into a database that contains the
geometry for publicly available furniture
pieces and find which ones are seen in the
image!
So here's what we do: given a large amount
of training samples, neural networks are adept
at recognizing objects on a photograph.
That would be step number one.
After the identification, the algorithm knows
where the object is, now we're interested
in what it looks like and how it is aligned.
And then, we start to look up public furniture
databases for objects that are as similar
to the ones presented in the photo as possible.
Finally, we put everything in its appropriate
place, and create a new digital image with
a light simulation program.
This is an iterative algorithm, which means
that it starts out with a coarse initial guess
that is being refined many many times until
some sort of convergence is reached.
Convergence means that no matter how hard
we try, only minor improvements can be made
to this solution.
Then, we can stop.
And here, the dissimilarity between the photograph
and the digitally rendered image was subject
to minimization.
This entire process of creating the 3D geometry
of the scene takes around 5 minutes.
And this technique can also estimate the layout
of a room from this one photograph.
Now, this algorithm is absolutely amazing,
but of course, the limitations are also to
be candidly discussed.
While some failure cases arise from misjudging
the alignment of the objects, the technique
is generally quite robust.
Non-cubic room shapes are also likely to introduce
issues such as the omission or misplacement
of an object.
Also, kitchens and bathrooms are not yet supported.
Note that this is not the only paper solving
this problem, I've made sure to link some
more related papers in the video description
for your enjoyment.
If you have found this interesting, make sure
to subscribe and stay tuned for more Two Minute
Papers episodes!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!